[Musik]
do
mein schöpfer
[Musik]
wie kannst du nur so lieblos und
verschwenderisch mit dem von mir
geschaffenen umgehen
[Musik]
ich denke doch dass ich ein werk deine
hände bin
wenn ich keine liebe bekommen kann dann
will ich furcht und entsetzen verbreiten
die öden schritt halten und traurigen
flammen sollen meine zufluchtsorte sein
[Musik]
jubelnd werde ich meinen scheiterhaufen
besteigen und mich freuen an den
lodernden flammen die mich umzingelt die
flamme wird in sich zusammensinken
und der wind wird meine asche weithin
über das endlose mehr tragen
[Musik]
ich habe mich verliebt
ausgerechnet jetzt wo ich in meiner
abschlussarbeit sitzen müsste
heute abend kommt er vorbei
er hat sich was süßes gewünscht
und ich backe monate aller karl menth
brauche ich nur noch ein hörgerät
das kaufen eines neuen produktes lösten
gewisses glücksgefühl aus das ist
richtig wenn ich mir neuen fernseher
kaufen stell dein zuhause hin lösen
damit ein glücksgefühl aus wenn das auch
nur drei wochen hält bis ich mich daran
gewöhnt aber das ist durchaus das ist
durchaus so das ist wie beim
schuhekaufen
[Musik]
ich glaube es gibt immer noch produkte
die viele viele jahre halten wenn wir
die reparatur rechnet ist besser man
kauft euch ich würde ich nicht mehr weg
damit ich möchte was neues die lösung
wäre den kapitalismus abzuschaffen mehr
muss ich dazu nichts auf
ja
20 euro
[Musik]
perfekt
und sogar noch rechtzeitig
dort parallel am arsch
[Musik]
echt super arbeit
erst nach der mixa schlapp und jetzt
werde ich versetzt
kann man sich denn ich nichts mehr
verlassen
auf menschen nicht
und auch nicht auf dinge
[Musik]
was für ein seltsamer traum
ich habe getanzt
aber mit wem
was sind das alles für sachen
warum hat man die weggeworfen
es sei doch noch gar nicht alt
konnte man euch nicht mehr reparieren
oder von an euch nicht mehr schön
warum kaufe ich selber sachen die ich
kurz danach wieder wegschmeißen
was für eine beziehung habe ich
eigentlich zu meinen ding
[Applaus]
es gibt noch dinge die uns nicht im
stich lassen
wunderschöne dinge
zb mein neues altes rührgerät
es heißt rg 28
und das ist mindestens 30 jahre alt
vielleicht sogar 40 aber das spannendste
es ist ein waschechter ob sie
hergestellt in einem volkseigenen
betrieb
in der ddr
ist das dein geheimnis
[Musik]
mein hörgerät wurde in suhl gebaut einem
ort in thüringen
bis zum ende der ddr unglaubliche 18
millionen mal
heute ist ein stück designgeschichte
ich will wissen was für ein betrieb
dieses elektrogeräte merk war
ich will die menschen kennenlernen die
meinen rg 28 gebaut haben
ich bin gespannt ob hier in so noch
jemand meinen ärger 28 kennt
oder dieses elektrogeräte werk
entschuldigung ich habe eine frage
kennen sie das elektrogeräte werk so
sagt man das kannte ich schon lange das
gibt es gar nicht mehr ich habe eine
frage nicht schlimm ist
ich wollte fragen kennt ihr das
elektrogeräte werks nun zeigt euch das
was
ich habe schon was davon gehört aber
weiß nicht wo das ist oder ob sie
überhaupt das noch gibt oder so nicht
geben uns aber nicht gibt's nicht
ich weiß es
nicht
kennen sie das elektrogeräte wechselt er
zeigen ja sagt ihnen das was ja sicher
gibt es noch nie es gibt es nicht mehr
seit der wende das dann den bach
runtergegangen jungen
und darf ich fragt warum sie das kennen
haben sie dabei jetzt auch meine mutter
hat dort gearbeitet und verwandtschaft
welche die haben dort gearbeitet
weil ich hab so ein ärger und 20 hause
gibt es auch ab und zu noch ich habe
auch mal rollen als sie haben auch noch
nicht funktioniert dann noch ja
funktioniert entschuldigung ich hab ne
frage
ich bin auf den spuren des rg 28
[Musik]
ich hatte den
jetzt
und jetzt ist aber und jetzt ist er weg
genau haben sie das ding gemacht
nein hab ich auch noch ja wohl den habe
ich bestimmt 30 jahre weil das
qualitätsarbeit war und was meint ihr
liegt es dass das damals einfach ein
anderes gearbeitet um ja wahrscheinlich
das ist mir sehr schwer gefallen was
neues zu kaufen und wir haben dann
irgendwas genommen und danach hatte das
überhaupt keine leistung und wir haben
dann noch mal was zweites gekauft so war
dann genau auf die waage achtet haben
und das ganz einfach was gar nicht da
was ebenbürtiges zu finden ich treffe
erstaunlich viele menschen die noch
einen ärger 28 zu hause haben
einige besuche ich in ihrer küche zum
beispiel kerstin schmidt
sie hat zu ddr-zeiten selbst im
elektrogeräte werk gearbeitet
als facharbeiterin für plaste
das ist eher stützen dazu und alles was
grob gehackt werden soll kommt hier oben
rein und dann halt
also dass rührgerät
habe ich gekauft
1981 und den vario block 12 jahre später
dazu
ist es immer kaputt gegangen seither aus
dass die hülle mal das ist also das ist
runtergefallen und da das natürlich hat
das ist es natürlich zu sprung und
daraufhin habe ich dann ja ein neues
eine neue ein neues gehäuse bekommen
aber sonst aber dass diese das ist ja
das innenleben ist also nach wie vor das
alte das ursprünglich also muss man auch
nie irgendwas informieren oder nach
schrauben man braucht kein öl und nix
also es läuft wie einst und die ja aber
ein gerät das man so lange hat dann
erkennt man
kennt an eindruck am gewicht oder wie
auch immer man merkt jede veränderung
dieser erinnerung das ist ja etwas was
das leben ausmacht
und ich denke so ist das bei einem gerät
das man so lange hatte ist das einfach
auch eine gute erinnerung das ist schwer
es liegt gut in der hand es ist
reduziert es ist robust
ich weiß von vielen bekannten die haben
dieses gerät wirklich bis zum heutigen
tag auch im gebrauch und es tut nach 40
jahren noch seinen dienst ich habe mir
jetzt eben das für meiner schwägerin
genehm da ist es noch richtig in betrieb
und in der anderen verfahren schafft
wenn er nicht da ist es jetzt schon vier
wochen hat
sein was auch noch in gebrauch
[Musik]
in china kommen
da war in der packung interessant
untergebracht und internet
nach der montage
[Musik]
in mehreren reihen links in die haller
ist nicht durch auf
mehreren
seiten
das ist zwar eine alle
[Musik]
einen tag nachdem werner triebel mich
durch die alte montagehallen geführt hat
besuche ich ihn zu hause
den größten teil seines lebens war er
gruppenleiter im bereich technologie
einen rg 28 kennt er wie kein anderer
das
einleben
die hohen bälle an wo die genäht werden
einkommen usw das ist so kühlung das
mädchen da hinten rücken und das ist der
anschluss für schlagzeuger milch starb
unter die räder kommen die knete mental
um die schlafgewohnheiten
ein vorgehensmodell also beide 3 war der
start am hochgeschlossen das mussten
dieses spiel bier um die bowle
validieren zustand gewickelt währende
war sehr aufwändig oder schlauer mensch
hat es fertiggebracht ja der staat aber
ist hier nur hingegen geschlossen
und die 2g hoch und die schule jeweils
auf einer lang video maschine
also schwerlich an die gewickelten nur
noch auf diesen
geschenken also den staffeln drauf
gedrückt das ist alles was wirklich dass
rationell zu produzieren gewesen
das heißt hohlwelle
hogan ja ich hole
und das heißt die schnecke schläge und
die macht was die drei
eingesteckt und
das konstruktiv so durchgestylt dass er
nicht noch zu verbessern ist
und
wenn was kaputt geht oder falsch
behandelt wird an diesem gerät ist es
dass sie überlastet wird das heißt wenn
sie mit den knethaken ganz steigen diese
vorbilder dass der schwache punkt das
heißt dass die schnecke die zähne hier
deformiert und
er ist nicht mehr funktionstüchtig ist
und das dauert doch keine zehn minuten
hat mit einer anderen bühne eingebaut
oder geht es war ja bei den normalen
gebrauch ist es unkaputtbaren wieder
trabant und
das ist auch nicht gegen st das haben
sie hat ein zehn minuten hat man das
heutzutage meinen sie die die die sachen
kann man gar nicht nicht mal mehr mehr
öffnen
antriebs keine waren zu gucken
ich muss das gerät zerstört
dann kann man sich ja
ich meine es fast als verbrechen
dass man so ein werk die folie gute
produkte hergestellt hat einfach den
erdboden gleich gemacht hat
ich vermute ich kann sich beweisen aber
ich vermute ganz stark dass mit diesen
aktionen die konkurrenz ausgeschaltet
worden ist
wenn die planwirtschaft sinnvoll
angewandt worden er hätte die chance
gehabt
ich habe einen termin im staatsarchiv in
suhl
früher war es mal ein gefängnis heute
lagern hier riesige mengen unterlagen
aus der ddr-zeit
15 regal meter allein zum elektrogeräte
werk
mitte der 80er jahre arbeiten ungefähr
4000 menschen im werk
fast jeder in der gegend hatte etwas mit
dem betrieb zu tun
von hier aus belieferte man die gesamte
ddr mit haushaltsgeräten
dazu noch das sozialistische und nicht
sozialistische ausland
[Musik]
produziert wurden alles schneider
staubsauger luft duschen
und ein legendäres rührgerät
das war sozusagen das vlies waren ja ihr
runde wurde es gebaut hat jeder mehrere
arbeitsgänge komma sie hat dieses gerät
geprüft hat hier auch wurde die show
aufnahme alles geprüft hier wurde da
dies die letzten schrauben eingesetzt
wurde hierüber geschoben sie hat es
kontrolliert auf durchgang auflauf und
alles diese ältere kollegin hat es
geputzt und die wo dann so eine quote
festgestellt wenn man viele fehler
durchgelassen haben war dann halt
schlecht für uns so sorgten der hat
nicht nur stichproben gemacht die hat
jedes angenommen und dann wurde aus
gestempelten hatte jeder einen
persönlichen stempel in die oberschale
kam dann stempel wurde geguckt wenn es
also verschulden von dem mitarbeiter
wenn sie material fehler war kommt mir
nichts dazu also runter war schon jeder
bestrebt seine sache richtig zu machen
also jedes hörgerät hatte seinen stellen
nämlich zum beispiel sich die sieben
musiker den stich sieben einsätzen den
stempel ich habe 65 die lehrer begonnen
bis 67 elektro montieren ist ihr beruf
und anker wickle mich am reparatur steht
ja dann wechsele ich gerade die sowohl
wählen
monatsende beim plan ich öffne deine kam
alles ins
büro leute werkzeugbau die männer
mussten alle kommt weil es nicht
geschafft haben die männer haben immer
gestört die wollten da hat er auch keine
sitzfleisch wenn er da sitzen muss und
musste jemand rufen wenn er zur toilette
musste schon alles so bislang
gewöhnungsbedürftig oder wohl eher was
denkst du jetzt weg werfen dich hier
haben muss ich schon ein bisschen
mussten schon beziehen weil ja einer von
anderen abhängig war um die endsumme hat
gezählt auch fürs geld
aber schon kaputt und ich wollte fragen
ob sie das einmal zeigen können wie man
sowas überhaupt aufmacht damit wird das
mal mit dem den vergleich mit
irgendwelchen schrauben mit lina hier
doch da oben stehen bis jetzt gibt es
noch eine schlage auch irgendwas
weinberger hat ihr ganzes arbeitsleben
im elektrogeräte werk verpasst
ich hab ich ja noch was waren dann die
letzten schrauben
viele menschen bringen hier heute noch
ihre kaputten geräte weil irgendwer hat
sie mit hingabe repariert
bitten das ist doch schon
3 active das ist ja wieder anders sehen
sie da habe ich das das war der mut das
war der letzte ich bin die modernsten
schraube die bayern erst hat schrauben
zuerst hab mir das war natürlich alle
erst dann hat unser kreuz schlitz und
das war dann bei den neuen schon nach
und nach der wende aber das ist wieder
ein anderes kinderklinik vor allem ein
schräubchen was ich noch nicht kann er
also ich weiß nicht das gericht nicht
auf also kein mensch hat ja
dann können wenn man sozusagen nur mit
dem hammer drauf hauen oder oder
auseinander eisen bricht aber die
plastik auseinander alles in welcher
beziehung stehenden die menschen die zu
ihm kommen und sagen auch helfen wenn
wir doch mal sagen also das ist mal gut
das war gut die heutige doch nichts weg
wer das gerät es ist halt so sagte es
hat
kapitalismus
soll ja immer weiter gehen die leute
brauchen junge arbeitet muss man also
ein ding hier 30 jahre hält ist ja nicht
sinn und zweck der sache so ja was neues
soll ja weitergehen
[Musik]
ich habe eigentlich vertrete mechaniker
gelernt habe nach der armeezeit ein
studium begonnen und bin nach dem
studium im damaligen elektroräder
wechsel sofort als prüfingenieur
gelandet und wir haben da im prinzip
lebensdauer und zuverlässigkeitsprüfung
von küchengeräten gemacht
das ist jetzt der eigentliche prüft nun
kann man sich vorstellen dass man
zweimal 48 stunden nicht mit der
kuchenteig prüfen kann deshalb haben wir
als ersatzlösung
da sieht man hier an diesem topf über
mehrere stufen mal
von der konsistenz her ein mittel
gesucht wo man auch über die gesamt
prüfzeit prüfen kann und diese brühe die
da drin ist das ist nichts anderes wie
maschinen öl vermischt mit zinkoxid so
also man muss sich jetzt vorstellen ich
fühle jetzt diese masse in diesem
behälter rein und dann passiert die
prüfung eigentlich nur so dass ich dir
jetzt einschalten
haben kurz darüber gesprochen wie lange
ich früheren darf ich darf also fünf
minuten rühren und dann haben wir immer
25 minuten pause gemacht und das wurde
überall die schaltuhr gewährleistet also
dann kommen eben diese laufzeiten die
diese geräte angebracht haben von 20 25
jahren raus zumal sie eben auch sehr
robust gebaut worden sind mit nirosta
wohl wählen wobei heutigen geräten
generell
positiverer kunststoffe eingesetzt wird
und wo es soll heute dem gerät
eigentlich auch noch lange erhalten ich
habe sehr gerne gäste arbeit
mit sehr guten kollegen
ich will mal so sagen wir sehen immer
sehr gut miteinander klargekommen vom
kleinsten arbeiter bis zum ingenieur wir
haben ja zum beispiel auch als
angestellte jedes jahr vier wochen
produktionseinsatz gemacht sind wir in
die rollende schicht gekannt wie wir die
kunststofffertigung oder haben selber
die hörgeräte zusammengeschraubt man
eine woche lang so was wird gemacht und
das schweißt denke ich auch ein bisschen
mehr zusammengeht entwickelt bisschen
verständnis für den anderen ich war auch
so eingestellt wenn ich mal hingegangen
bin da wollte ich habe nicht die blauen
sein da habe ich eben auch versucht die
normen zu schaffen und das war eben auch
gar nicht so einfach man wusste was die
leute da unten leisten das waren
zusammenspiel der ganzen truppe vom
konstrukteur angefangen bis zum hofer
weiter
es war ein erfolgsrezept
nach feierabend nicht mehr zusammen
weckmann ist gegenseitig konkurrent in
vielen fällen dass das alles nicht
ich bin tief beeindruckt von den
menschen die meinen ärger 28 gebaut
haben
man spürt dass sie stolz auf ihre arbeit
war
rainer schäfer erzählte mir dass man
miteinander und nicht gegeneinander
gearbeitet hat
ist das das geheimnis meines rg 28
ist er das relikt einer gescheiterten
utopie
[Musik]
das muss doch noch viel mehr geben von
diesem guten zeitlosen gebrauchs den
im thüringischen arnstadt stoße ich auf
den sammler christian böhm von
kindesbeinen an bin ich großer sammler
betreiben asche doch kleines privates
museum und stand dann plötzlich anfang
der 90er jahre vor sperrmüllhaufen mit
ungeheuer vielen habseligkeiten
wunderbaren objekt die eigentlich bis zu
dem moment ihre funktion erfüllt haben
und plötzlich als unnütz sind auf der
straße landeten kennst du das rg 28
natürlich wieder ein paar exemplare bei
uns hier in der sammlung es ist ein
robustes gerät mit einer extrem
reduzierten form und wenn man es dann
noch in dieser orange färbung hat also
hat ist es wirklich etwas ikonenhaft
dass uns das ist eigentlich ein
stückchen designgeschichte eigentlich
dieses
honorierte rg 28 ist reines rühren also
es ist nicht mehr drum herum er
sozusagen
es ist im positiven sinne eigentlich
keine schaumschlägerei
also wenn man dieses geräusch wird wie
die rührbesen aneinander schlagen also
denkt ja immer an meiner ostpreußische
oma die mit dem gerät seine geschlagen
hat wenn große geburtstagsfeiern
anstanden oder den teig geknetet hat für
den
kuchen oder für den kuchen sind nicht
gern gegessen habe
was ist denn eigentlich mit diesem
ganzen sachen passiert wo sind die
hingegangen sie wurden ein stück weit
den monsters und galten dann wirklich so
als ikonen sozusagen dieses
untergegangenen landes und viele leute
haben sich einfach davon freimachen
wollen trennen wollen und haben die
einfach auf den sterne gestellt
weggeschmissen und die sachen wurden
dann durch billige andere dinge aus
taiwan oder irgendwo ersetzt
am wochenende ist es tatsächlich so dass
ganze gruppen von menschen hier davon
stehen und plötzlich anfangen
geschichten zu erzählen und darum geht
es eigentlich
diese konsumgüterproduktion in der ddr
hat sie eine ganz andere bedeutung die
ursachen waren wirklich auf
langlebigkeit ausgelegt
ich frage mich auf unsere beziehung zu
den dingen ein abbild unseres
gesellschaftssystems ist
macht es einen unterschied ob man dinge
herstellt um einen unternehmer noch ein
bisschen reicher zu machen
oder ob man dinge produziert weil man
glaubt dass die menschen sie wirklich
brauchen
also nach der zweijährigen ausbildung
wurden wir dann auch ganz feierlich in
unser kollektiv in denen wir ja zwei
jahre gearbeitet haben in der praxis
ganz feierlich aufgenommen
dazu gab es eine urkunde oder an der
privatier also wollte sagte man chef der
mannschaft der vertrauensmann und der
fdj sekretär
unterschrieben hat also das war schon
ganz was besonderes das hat also nicht
jeder gemacht und hat seine lehrlinge im
prinzip feierlich in die private
sozialen dann ins regelrechter
arbeitsleben aufgenommen deutlich wurde
das auch festgehalten dass ist ein foto
von mir das ist meine lehre ausbilderin
dessen sie ja
ja das ist es wie gesagt ein bild vom
schreibtisch von meiner jugend arbeitern
im betrieb
bei der fdp bei der fdj
dann ja noch ein original comets eine
betriebszeitung aus 1987
das ist ein bild wo alte und junge
revolutionäre
aufeinandergetroffen sind das sind im
prinzip veteranen die mal im egs
gearbeitet haben und dazu sind immer
jugendliche eingeladen worden dass man
sich halt untereinander austauscht wie
war denn das damals erzählt doch mal und
ja das war eine ganz nette runde
das sind also noch zeitzeugen ja und
dann gab es natürlich für mich
persönlich ein ganz besondere ehre das
war eine beilage damals im freien wort
ja und ja da wollte ich zu einem fdj
kongress oder arbeiterjugend kongress
der fc hürth delegiert frieden war ja
auch immer ein großes thema erster juni
hier stand ich in suhl auf dem heutigen
platz der deutschen einheit damals hieß
es noch ins thema an platz und habe ja
meine emotionen für den frieden erwähnt
was macht man für den frieden ja indem
man halt ja so wird es uns vielleicht
auch suggeriert jeden tag seine arbeit
gut macht und
damit den staat und den frieden stärkt
ja
und das ist also noch ein original
hälfte j und ich hoffe es passt noch
das sieht ganz gut aus da es passt und
das passt noch
so war das ganze
schick glauben ja und dann bin ich noch
jung aktivist geworden das sind meine
zweier ist auszeichnungen also auch für
gute oder für seriöse arbeit wollte ich
dann in der brigade ausgezeichnet da
wurde ich als einzelperson als
einzelperson das gab es jetzt als einen
so passieren und so sah das ganze aus
und das würde dann ja oder anderen augen
angeheftet
[Musik]
es gibt noch zwei drei ihrer person
nebenan ab und an mal einen blick recht
wenn man sich dann mal trifft dann wird
auch ordentlich kinder
[Applaus]
[Musik]
bild
der start für den diese menschen
gearbeitet
existiert nicht mehr
können wir trotzdem noch etwas
nützliches in den trümmern dieser utopie
finden
hast du gesehen dort erneut
[Musik]
[Applaus]
denn geschehen
wann
[Musik]
hast du gesehen dort kommt die neue zeit
es wird geschehen sind wir dafür
dortmund
ich wollte wissen was ein befürworter
der marktwirtschaft zur planwirtschaft
zu sagen hat
ich frage den wirtschaftsprofessor
andreas freytag ökonom an der
universität jena
also das ist ja
in der planwirtschaft nicht
ausgeschlossen dass gute produkte im
sinne der funktionalität hergestellt und
rührgerät wird wahrscheinlich relativ
einfach aufgebaut sein in dem sinne dass
die funktionalität
das besteht darin dass die
informationsverarbeitung in einer
planwirtschaft nicht funktioniert weil
so viele kundenwünsche existieren so
viele unterschiedliche kleine teile an
informationen überall herum schwirren
dass die von einer zentralen
planungsstelle niemals vollständig
erfasst werden können und deshalb ist es
so schwierig für eine planungskommission
so etwas oder von in einer
planwirtschaft zuerst zu entwickeln
zumal ja in der planwirtschaft für sehr
viele planen dann muss die nicht alle
gleich denken und nicht alle wollen das
gleiche produkt und sie können gar nicht
wissen was sie alle wollen wer weiß was
die leute brauchen und das ist sehr
kompliziert
herauszuarbeiten
am einfachsten geht es für den
preismechanismus
wenn etwas sehr teuer ist und ich es
trotzdem kaufen dann werde ich es
wahrscheinlich brauchen wenn nicht nur
haben will weil es gerade moderne
im kapitalistischen system
versprochen sie wissen sie brauchen sind
zwar ja nicht mehr dann wird es keinen
sinn etwas zu kaufen was in 60 jährige
lebensdauer verspricht
müssen wir den ökonomen glauben
kann der kampf um den niedrigsten preis
oder die neueste innovation
langfristig etwas gutes bewirken
und die industrie wird immer wieder was
neues erfinden damit die leute was neues
kaufen sie möchten nicht mehr mit einem
handy von vor zehn jahren telefonieren
sondern sie wollen smartphone lose
unterwegs ins internet gehen können wo
sie bilder schicken können wo sie sich
in soziale netzwerke einbinden lassen
können wer will das heute nicht mehr
ich habe mich mit wolfgang list
verabredet
auch er studierte
wirtschaftswissenschaften
allerdings in der ddr
später hat er sich im elektrogeräte werk
um den vertrieb gekümmert danach wurde
der buchhändler
wenn ich richtig zieht ihre einheit von
einheit von wirtschafts- und
sozialpolitik genau da gehe ich mal
davon aus dass man hier doch schon auch
um staatliche für der gesellschaft wie
sie interesse hatte einen gebrauchswert
zu schaffen die kein gerät also ich
morgen mal verkaufen können wenn ich den
wert realisieren und den preis sondern
ich bei von kindern gebraucht werden das
team soll berühren und mixen nicht
morgen ein neues ausgetauscht werden was
in den werten deutet hin der
gebrauchswert von ihm vorbeikommen gibt
es die schlagworte ich kaufe also bin
ich meine man geht der dörfer aus
dass vielleicht 70 prozent dessen was
heute produziert wird völlig unnötig ist
man bedenkt dass in manchen firmen ja
der werbeetat größer als die
personalkosten wissen bedarf muss erst
geschaffen werden und wenn dann mit
unnützen sachen zu befriedigen
das wär ja auch so gewesen wenn alle
geräte ewig halten wird ein groß weil
das wirtschaftswachstum der gang
gekommen was glauben sie warum den
menschen da einfach so mitmachen ja wir
menschen ist so ein komischer ausdruck
ich mache gar nicht habe nicht mal ein
mobile proben das wort bemüht sich nicht
so gerne und warum man sich mir sage des
menschen das vor zehn zwanzig jahren
noch auch kommunizieren konnten wenn man
dann noch abreden getroffen hat hat mir
auch eingehalten werden im konjunktiv
könnte hätte würd ich rufe die noch mal
an den start es ist einfach
haben sie dadurch das gefühl dass sie
irgendwie ausgeschlossen sind von
gewissen ging
am stadtrand von chemnitz gibt es ein
riesiges lager mit gebrauchsgütern aus
ddr produktion
für die beiden gründer jens burkhardt
und jörg schaarschmidt ist es ein
lebensprojekt diese guten alten dinge
vor dem vergessen zu bewahren
sie hoffen darauf dass sie eines tages
wieder so wertgeschätzt werden wie sie
es verdienen
wir haben vor 20 jahren begonnen sachen
zu verkaufen die auf dem sperma
herumlagen also die leute haben die
sachen weggeschmissen haushalte
aufgelöst einfach auf die straße
gestellt und wir haben das zusammen
getragen und verkauft alles was
irgendwie nach ddr recht
tragen wir ja zusammen also angefangen
von der gebrauchten zahnbürste bis hin
zum schrank ich finde das halt schade
dass das was damals produziert wurde
einfach verschwindet
das waren ja auch schöne sachen das
waren eine zeitlose sachen und
jedes teil ist ja mit irgendeinem
menschen verbunden oder mit mehreren und
wenn es die seele gibt
dann haben wir natürlich auch seele was
für eine beziehung haben wir zu unseren
dingen heute
es gibt alles im überfluss man kann
alles kaufen
und man kauft doppelt und das ist
traurig
ich habe auch mit konsumiert drogen
konsumiert wie hier der andere
oder die meisten aber es gibt glaube ich
ein umdenken bei den leuten bei vielen
das halt nicht mehr nur mehr mehr mehr
mehr braucht es denn
wir sind ja nur die konsumenten und wir
haben die wahl
billig zu kaufen oder teuer zu kaufen
und wenn dann aber ein produkt halt
teuer ist weil das halt nicht von
kindern hergestellt wurde zum beispiel
es ist auf jeden fall besser als
irgendein
der muss es ein umdenken bei allen geben
das schaffen weiß ich nicht
also angefangen von von den produzenten
bis hin zum konsumenten
[Musik]
kriegt man das hin
schwierig
also ich war oft mit konsumieren für
mich
ich möchte wissen ob es so etwas wie ein
sozialistisches design gab im leipziger
grassimuseum habe ich mich mit dem
berliner sammler und kulturjournalisten
günter höhne verabredet
im jahr 2000
erschienen das erste mal einen design
lexikon deutschland und dieses schrieb
auf seinen ersten seiten in also was da
im osten basiertes müssen wir gar nicht
berücksichtigen denn es gab kein eigenes
ddr design und was sie gemacht haben
waren oft
kopien von dem was im westen gängig war
und wir können also darauf verzichten
das gab's natürlich ausschließlich
keiten und jetzt bloß
dass darauf ausgerechnet ddr design
reduziert wurde nach der wende das hat
mich das hat mich angetrieben inzwischen
gab es eine grenze mitten durch
deutschland inzwischen gab es embargos
dadurch entstand natürlich eine relativ
überschaubare palette von auch
technischem gebrauchsgut aber wie gesagt
die musste
lange ihren dienst tun aber eben nicht
nur als gerät sondern nun kann der
gestalter oder die gestalterin ins spiel
die gesagt haben wir müssen auch eine
anmut haben eine
äußere kultur die den menschen
eigentlich von vornherein daran hindert
zu sagen nach zwei jahren ich will dich
nicht mehr weg damit ich möchte was
neues zu sagen
das war schon eine über jahrzehnte an
sich entwickeln
unausgesprochene kultur oder
unausgesprochenes gesetz wir machen
dinge die sich lange gebrauchte wären
es war eine ganz andere
produktphilosophie auch reparatur
freundlich
ergänzungs fähig
erweiterungsfähig und beständig also
ordentliche verarbeitung
und nicht dieses dieses auch ein weg
damit und und was neues gibt dann noch
ein ganz schönes spiel das gebrauch ich
am liebsten aus einem ganz anderen
sektoren nicht technisches gerät sondern
da wurde in weißwasser im kombinat leise
zur glas ein neues glas entwickelt mit
einer besonderen
technologie die es so gut wie aber fast
unzerbrechlich machte das kann nicht aus
der höhe hier auf den boden fallen
lassen es springt einmal hoch und geht
nicht kaputt promis diese serie dann
auch super fest kam so 1980 etwa
nicht in den handel sondern in die
gaststätten es war ein wirklich glas
stapelbar und in verschiedenen größen
1990 wurde die produktion in schwepnitz
dann auch eingestellt die haben eine
jahresproduktion von weit über neun
millionen gehabt und es kam ein neuer
besitzer aus dem westen und der hat
gesagt weg dieser maschinen weg dieses
sortiment ich bin doch nicht blöd dass
ich hier lese herstellen dass er die
meine eigene existenz gefährdend ich
will gläser die zerbrechlich sind wie
hat sich die beziehung zu unseren dingen
in den letzten jahren und jahrzehnten
verändert und wie ist das heute
es gab im vergleich zu heute und damals
auch
zur westlichen waren kultur eine viel
engere bindung der menschen an die dinge
oder der dinge an die menschen vom hof
arbeiter bis zum
gestalter und zum maschineneinrichter es
gab bei vielen im bewusstsein wir wollen
das für uns machen
also meiner erfahrung nach gibt es
solche dichte mehr zwischen mensch und
dem was er produziert wirtschaft immer
weniger
ich glaube die es nur noch in der
bildenden kunst vorhanden und im
kunsthandwerk
ich möchte mir selbst ein bild von der
arbeit eines kunsthandwerkers machen
ich besuche georg beckmann in seiner
töpferwerkstatt in oberfranken
vielleicht haben wir uns ja auch deshalb
von unserem gebrauchs dingen entfremdet
weil wir die menschen die sie herstellen
nicht mehr kennen
[Musik]
ins land
mit den daumen
ist der arbeitsschritt wir jetzt wieder
zu
[Musik]
da
die wanddicke ist dünner geworden
so schön
[Musik]
um das töpfern zu erlernen muss man sich
auf das material ton auf den prozess das
drehen auf der scheibe hundertprozentig
einlassen sonst wird es nichts
ich glaube dass durch das töpferhandwerk
durch das töpfern hab ich
einen besonderen zugang zu den dingen
ich sehe die die basis von dem kreis ich
spüre die geplante erde die rauigkeit
und so weiter
da
habe ich
[Musik]
da kann ich lernen dass ich auch dass
ich nicht
jedes jahr eine neue kollektion neues
release braucht man dass es darum geht
das was man hat respektvoll zu genießen
das müsst ihr euch mal angucken wie die
glasur sich in der tiefe verändert da
ist ein muster eingeprägt nur was nur so
ganz zart durch scheint wie eine gestalt
die im nebel auftaucht unten spürst das
material den ton die rauigkeit spürst
den einfluss von von von feuer und von
dämpfen die im ofen gewerbe sind und und
ich glaube solche solcher natürlich
veredelten
gegenstände wenn man sich mal darauf
eingeht einfach mal drauf eingelassen
hat können einem schon
sind wien den lehrmittel dass man
eigentlich mit allem so gesehen könnte
wäre es nicht gut wenn es mehr dinge
gäbe die uns offenbarten wie und von wem
sie gemacht wurden
vielleicht würde mit diesem wissen auch
unsere wertschätzung wachsen
also ein kunsthandwerker hat er ein sehr
überschaubares publikum ja die kommen
und gehen und dann können sie sagen ist
gut oder hast du jetzt nicht so gut
gemacht ist überschaubar aber wenn man
für die industrieproduktion arbeitet und
sich vorstellen muss dass der eigene
entwurf im grunde in jedem haushalt
stehen kann in denen man kommt dann kann
man einfach nicht spielen sondern dann
muss man sehr verantwortungsvoll
arbeiten
ja man muss es einfach mal erwähnen weil
die stückzahlen in der produktion
zusammen gekommen sind die sind
international nicht
sozialistischen ländern undenkbar also
die wirkung die dann ein entwurf
innerhalb eines mehr oder weniger sagt
man einen gemauerten sagt man umgrenzten
bereich ist dann hagen konnte die waren
immens
ich bin zu besuch bei jörg und angelika
petrus hat
gemeinsam haben die beiden viele jahre
lang die zeitschrift form und zweck
herausgegeben
jörg petrus hat lehrt als professor für
designtheorie an der kunsthochschule
weißensee in berlin
wenn ich eine ausstellung machen würde
in der man das design des westens und
das design des ostens zusammenbringt
dann würde diese ausstellung für das
design uns nicht gut ausgehen
man würde sehen dass die artefakte die
da stehen die sind leiser die sind
bescheiden die drängen sich nicht in den
vordergrund
die sagen nicht nämlich mit
sondern die sagen vielleicht bestenfalls
vertrau mir ich bin das einzige was es
gibt
da ist eine zurückhaltung auch in den
entwürfen darin die daher kommt dass
diese art wollte die designobjekte nie
in einem regal haben konkurrieren müssen
mit anderen arten
also wenn es um besonderheit im ddr
design geht würde ich sagen
die ihnen man sieht den adolf hatten
eher sowas wie eine kameradschaftliche
struktur an es die passen auch als
einzelner objekte ganz gut in einem
arrangement von dingen die es schon gab
sie sind in vielerlei hinsicht anti
modisch oder nicht modisch und die
passende reihen
immer noch ich glaube dass das auch ein
geheimnis ist warum einige
abgesehen von der aussage kann an diesen
fakten interessiert sind weil die ihm
gibt die fügen sich ein es ist kein
angst handel von solisten oder egoisten
wo jeder wo jedes jede art hat sagt
bitte sei aufmerksam auf mich ich bin
der entscheidende akteur hier
die welt ist so voller müll oder
übersetzt und es werden ja nicht die
rohstoffe knapp sondern die senken wir
haben nicht mehr dennoch senken in die
wir den müll ablagern können das ist das
zentrale problem
und wenn man auf dieser ebene
argumentiert versteht man auch das ein
zuwachs an stofflichkeit und
überhaupt auch ein verbrauch von
energetischen ressourcen aus dem aspekt
der vermüllung sich verbietet
[Musik]
nur ein teil der geräte die wir
wegwerfen landet in recyclingbetrieben
wie diesen
von hans jürgen richter und danach
zwicknagl den betreibern der anlage
möchte ich wissen vor welche
herausforderungen sie unsere schrott
berge stellen
kann nicht zufrieden sein wir haben
jahrelang vollzug überall
zeitlich ist ein toller
arbeitsprozess das ist schwere
körperliche arbeit und das kostet geld
das weder in der bevölkerung noch beim
hersteller auch wichtig die beachtung
findet
ich sage ich mir heute überlegen meine
waschmaschine geht kaputt dann komme ich
gar nicht auf die reparieren zu lassen
ich gebe doch für 350 euro ohne marken
waschmaschine
bei weltmeisterschaft olympiade der
weggeschmissen ich weiß nicht mehr gehen
sondern aber es gibt jetzt gerade
sonderangebote neue die
bildschirmdiagonalen und noch flacher
noch kleinerer rahmen damit eben neu
gekauft es kostet ja nichts es wurde
auch immer gesagt ich muss das kaufen es
ist energiesparender wasser sparender
als was ich was es alles für schöne
marketing argumente gibt etwas neues zu
kaufen
letztendlich natürlich ist neuer
geständig waren aber ich das wieder
reingeholt haben
dafür gehen schon vor
der bürger möchte ein einfaches system
haben er wird also ich gehe stark davon
aus da wird seine elektrische zahnbürste
auch nicht zum händler schleppen was das
wird weiterhin in anderen kanälen
verschwinden
[Musik]
im besten fall holt als zu hause und
bringt es irgendwann mal in der kiste
irgendwo im schlechtesten fall land
jetzt einfach in der restmülltonne
[Musik]
hier enden viele der leichtfertig
entsorgten dinge
dinge die man vielleicht reparieren oder
länger hätte nutzen können
hier brauchen sie ihr dasein aus
verwandeln sich in schlacke und in rauch
und verschwinden durch den schornstein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir verbrennen hier die dinge die nicht
mehr anders verwertbar sind aus müll
sperrmüll aus der bevölkerung die hier
im einzugsgebiet der anlage wohnen im
deutschen die zu 500 tonnen am tag
der betriebsleiter dieter weyprecht
führt mich durch seine
müllverbrennungsanlage
er zeigt mir wie der sogenannte resten
entsorgt wird
ich vertrete die meinung die
gesellschaftlichen verhältnisse führen
auch dazu dass in dem maße wie oder
abfall erzeugt wird wichtig ist dass man
diesen abfall wieder zurück führt durch
verwertungskette und die rohstoffe im
abfall wieder nutzt
[Musik]
wir produzieren immer noch viel zu viel
restmüll
müll der auf deponien landet oder
verbrannt wird
unser ziel müsste sein diese art von
abfällen von anfang an zu vermeiden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir glauben wir könnten ein reines
gewissen haben
weil all das was wir achtlos entsorgen
irgendwie in den kreislauf zurückkehrt
doch das ist ein irrtum
wie begann eigentlich die beziehung
zwischen menschen und ihren
gerätschaften
was waren die ersten dinge die unsere
vorfahren hergestellt haben
waren es verlängerung unseres körpers
waren sie dadurch noch so etwas wie ein
teil finden
[Musik]
ich frage den archäologen und
museumsleiter dr diethard walter in
weimar
die vergangenen jahrtausende sind alle
wahnsinnig spannend weil man eigentlich
in allen zeiten etwas über menschsein
affäre wir haben hier ein überblick über
400.000 jahre menschliche geschichte sie
lernen etwas über die lebens des lebens
umfeld des urgeschichtlichen menschen
sie erfahren etwas über
handwerkstechniken durch alle zeiten
hindurch also von der steinzeit bis in
die eisenzeit bis in die germanische
zeit in dem moment als der mensch als
mensch auf das bild der geschichte
getreten ist haben menschen auch
gerätschaften benutzt hat sich stein
gerätschaft zugerichtet hat sich holz
geräte zugerichtet hat die
werkzeugherstellung perfektionierte mir
auch die jahrtausende das begann mit der
zurichtung von knochen von großsäuger
die als werkzeug als schlag oder farbe
benutzt worden sind und das geht dann
weiter mit der zurichtung von feuerstein
geräten zur
hochspezialisierten gerätschaften
man kann nicht sagen dass menschen dinge
einfach so gemacht haben dass sie in den
frühen zeiten hatte jedes jeder
gegenstand eine bedeutung im leben sei
es ein ein spiritueller reisen ganz
praktischer wurden dinge so gebaut dass
sie möglichst lange gehalten haben
natürlich sollte die dinge möglichst
lange halten und wie erkennt beispiel
auch bei
jungsteinzeitlichen keramiken den
umstand dass sie gepflegt worden sind
das heißt dass man löcher hinein gebohrt
hat mit bast das wieder zusammen
gebunden hat mit birkenpech verschmiert
hat das hat natürlich wollen die mühe
gemacht dinge auch wieder noch einmal
für den gebrauch herzurichten wenn sie
diese brauchen bahn oder wenn sie kaputt
war und wir finden vor allen dingen den
jüngeren zeiten ganz häufig stücke die
eigentlich 80 100 oder 150 jahre älter
waren als der begräbnis zeitpunkt dieses
menschen gewesen ist
in diesen gräbern der frühen ackerbauern
liegen zwar ein gefäß legen gelegentlich
werkzeuge etwa einen kühlen kopf kann
darin der männer gab gelegen haben die
frauen hatten häufig schmuck
gelegentlich schmuck mit ins grab
bekommen und daneben kann es auch
vorkommen wie dem ein kraft dass der die
diese frau auf einer platte gelegenheit
das heißt dass der gegenstand wo sie das
mehl für das tägliche brot hergestellt
haben
[Musik]
was bedeutet es wenn menschen mit ihren
gerätschaften des stadt wurden
es ist tröstlich zu glauben dass unsere
dinge uns im jenseits begleiten
möchte ich einst mit meinem smartphone
beerdigt werden
oder mit meinem rührgerät
ich treffe mich mit josef freitag er ist
professor für dogmatik an der
theologischen fakultät erfurt
können sie sich vorstellen dass dinge
gegenstände auch so etwas wie eine seele
haben
ich glaube wir geben ihnen manchmal eine
seele wenn wir sehr vertraut werden
wenn wir mit ihnen umgehen wenn sie für
uns selber lebendig wird
ich denke mal konkret an meinen computer
da wo ich mit dem computer texte
schreibe oder
geschichten entstehen
überträgt sich etwas von diesem text und
den geschichten auf die geräte mit den
dichter und schriftsteller hat ein
eigenes verhältnis zu seiner
schreibmaschine früher und heute zu
seinem laptop wenn man den widmen oder
ich habe einen rucksack den muss nicht
vor ein paar jahren abgeben
der war auch eigentlich aufgebraucht
aber die ganzen bergtouren der letzten
30 jahre waren an diesem rucksack dann
gibt man nicht so leicht her
was glauben sie wie hat sich unser
umgang mit den dingen
verändert in den letzten jahren oder
letzten jahrzehnten ich habe mühsam
lernen müssen nicht dass dinge kaputt
gehen das passiert in sondern dass wir
einfach verbraucht sind und schon
produziert werden nur für eine bestimmte
zeit
ich glaube dass es als unser verhältnis
zu dingen heftigst bestimmt wird über
werbung regler die sein outfit ansehen
was ich damit einkaufen wir kaufen
sachen von der äußeren gestalt weil wir
nicht mehr verstehen was darin passiert
also handys und computer kaufen denn
nachdem die seien die zahlen aber apple
90 prozent aus luft
was versuchen wir mit konsum zu
überspielen oder zu erreichen warum
verfällt der mensch immer wieder dieser
verführung obwohl er ja eigentlich weiß
dass es eine verführung ist
ist der einfachste weg und geld haben
wir
wenn ich mir klar machte das geht anders
langfristiger oder nachhaltiger oder
tiefer dann musste ich mich selber
ändern und musste auf den anschlüssen
welt verzichten das mühsam
und das wäre eine konfrontation mit mir
selber und dann müsste ich im verhältnis
zu den dingen selber vorkommen
und mich damit auseinandersetzen
ich hielte das für einen vorteil weil
dann mit einem selber etwas passiert und
nur in der begegnung mit solchen
wirklichkeit und tut sich bei uns etwas
aber das ist anstrengend
ich glaube nicht nur das es anstrengung
sondern da merken wir dass wir geduld
brauchen dass wir zeit brauchen
dass wir uns auf etwas einlassen müssen
dass wir zulassen müssen dass etwas mit
uns macht dich nicht nur etwas habe
das sind alles dinge die nicht so ich
sag mal so erwachsen meistens vermeidet
man die
aber dann geht auch eine menge an
chancen von leben vorbei und all die
dinge die eine seele kriegen kriegen die
deswegen weil wir eine beziehung dazu
entwickeln weil die auch mit uns was tun
dürfen
ich habe ein paar freunde und bekannte
eingeladen ich will hören wie sie zu
ihren dingen stehen
natürlich möchte ich ihnen meinen neuen
freund vorstellen
erst
[Musik]
das funktioniert noch
fast dran pleitegegangen irgendwelche
sachen hergestellt nicht kaputt
ich habe mir gerne klamotten und
es macht mir spaß ich ja nicht mehr da
vom magen klammern und haben mir geraten
dass er werde so lange zeit extrem dorf
aus dem markt heraus wie sie hier sind
aber hat man kriegt ja wirklich nicht
raus nicht am preis oder irgendwelchen
sachen wie die hergestellt werden gibt
es eigentlich auch so genau deswegen
gilt es zu klamotten bei kaffee dazu
steht ja für ein treffen das kann ich
dann eher kaufen sie sagen ja schon habe
ich das noch nie gesehen also man müsste
nicht groß über die qualität des
produktes sondern auch über die
herstellung machte ich erkennen aber
wenn die leute sich freuen das ist aber
eigentlich weiß ich sagen viele nicht
leisten
möglich ist dieses euro bezahlt hast
dass du deinen namen bezahlt hast mir
garantiert dass er trotzdem das lange
hält
wenn mir ein objekt gefällt oder
irgendwie so schön getanzt hatte schale
die kaufe ich mir dann einfach auch wenn
die 40 euro kostet egal wenn ich kann
ich das leichter ausgeben also viele von
meinen freunden hätten das geld aber
trauen sich das dann vielleicht auch
einfach nicht für ein objekt wirklich
denen man diesen wert irgendwie so
zugeben ja wenn man das zulässt dass man
den wert das ist nicht einfach nur ein
praktischer gegenstand ist sondern dass
das ein wert für einen hut oder
dieses einige regner und das hast du
direkt und hat sich gefreut und heute
finde ich habe man aber die angst nicht
falsch zu entscheiden
zu hoffen ist auch ein gerät ist nicht
wirklich das ist verständlich im
fernsehen was du alles haben musst dass
du nicht brauchst und dafür schuftet du
machst dich kompetent aber die leute
kriegen geld für dinge die sie gar nicht
brauchen
mensch des 19 jahrhunderts des zum
schneider gang ist und hat sich einen
festtags anzug auf den leib schneidern
lassen wer hat denn dann halt sein leben
lang benutzt für feierliche anlässe und
uns so was gibt es heute natürlich nicht
mehr aber man könnte auch sagen ich geh
jetzt einmal im laden und kauft mir ein
richtig teil was haltbar ist und ist gut
und das ist unter menschenwürdigen
bedingungen produziert worden und das
trage ich dann so lange das so lange es
hält aber das ist jetzt nicht gerade
zeitgeistigen es gibt in der
in der umweltpolitik ein instrument
nämlich der versuch die gesamten kosten
eines produktionsprozesses dem
produzenten schrägstrich verursacher
schrägstrich konsumenten dann zu lassen
mal am ende des tages seine konsument
derjenige ist der das ganze verursacht
dh sie müsste es müsste möglich sein
über entweder steuer für filme oder über
emissionszertifikate darüber
kohlendioxid sprechen weltweit dafür zu
sorgen dass die vollen kosten der
produktion des transports und der
entsorgung in den produktpreis
einfließen dann würde ich sowieso
vermuten das ist eine ganze menge konsum
unterbleibt die flasche wein für einen
euro 59 aus chile oder das t shirt für
drei euro aus indien ob das dann noch
kommt ist die frage ob wir brauchen es
wahrscheinlich bei uns nicht aber
das ist der dass werden also über die
kosten weil es dann immer noch den
konsumenten das recht und erlaubt oder
überhaupt die möglichkeit erlaubt zu
sagen ich möchte trotzdem im urlaub nach
afrika fliegen auch wenn der flug jetzt
nicht mehr 800 euro kosten sondern 2000
an die folgekosten ja das ist denn meine
entscheidung sagt niemand das brauchst
du nicht sondern ich sage selber ich
will es nicht es ist ein unterschied ist
die art und weise wie wir heute
konsumieren wirklich nur ein
individuelles problem
können wir warten bis es überall auf der
welt gesetze gibt die uns zwingen
vernünftiger mit unseren gebrauchs
dingen zugehen
seit 2009 verbreitet sich eine neue idee
in europa
auch in erfurt wurde sie aufgegriffen
maria wale ist die mitinitiatorin eines
repair cafés
und dass er aber noch keinen sinn
unserer nähe kanten und gerne 1 hätten
oder ja gerne nord hätten wo
zusammenhang 1 machen können
denn jedes mal so verteilt über diese
drei stunden über das einmal und machen
sie ja maximal 20 leute aus so
das ist gut besucht auch wenn wir dafür
nicht viel tun spricht sich rum
die idee die dahinter steht ist dass es
jeder überall in seinem eigenen stadt
etablieren können also dass man überall
solche orte schaffen menschen hinkommen
die vielleicht auch nur besucht zu ihren
sachen haben die sie eben nicht
wegwerfen wollen die aber kann sie nicht
reparierbar sind und das ist seit dort
menschen die ihnen dabei helfen und
ihnen zeigen wie das geht
ganz einfach
und natürlich dass letztlich der active
agierens auch manchmal etwas aufbaut
oder wieder ganz macht und das finde ich
auf jeden fall ist ein befriedigendes
gefühl und vor einigen halt auch mit
anderen auf jeden fall zusammen und auch
über generationen hinweg und auch
menschen die man sonst wahrscheinlich
einfach noch nicht getroffen hätte
es bringt freude für den
abbau beziehungsweise hier bringt
und freude für den
jedes gerät hat seine eigenheiten die
älteren geräte sind eigentlich zur
reparatur nacht und die neuere
es ist auf jeden fall schwer in so einer
überdosierten welt ich das ist eine
logische folge dass man eben nicht zu
allem und jedem diese beziehung mehr
haben kann aber deswegen das halt die
frage worauf man sich konzentrieren ob
es dann nicht besser ist irgendwie
zumindest für mich halt wenige dinge zu
haben und mich darauf zu konzentrieren
schauen wer sie produziert und
vielleicht hat auch zu gucken dass ich
möglichst nah dran bin an dem ort oder
in die menschen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wie könnten wir wieder eine tiefere
dauerhafte beziehung zu unseren dingen
entwickeln
ich mache mich auf dem weg zu dem jungen
teilnehmern andreas sonnefeld und markus
leipzig
die beiden versuchen einen
alltagsgegenstand auf
verantwortungsvolle weise herzustellen
wir haben nicht wirklich eine beziehung
zu produkten weil wir auch nicht
kapieren was sie eigentlich sind also
was sie was sie in sich tragen wie sie
gemacht sind also dann würde ich halt
auch als und da fängt das wieder mit der
wäsche tragen ich kann ja auch keine
emotionale bindung zum team aufbauen
wenn ich das nicht so minute wieder
wegschmeißen kommen
heutzutage gehe ich in hd und kaufen wir
ein paar schuhe für sechs euro für mein
kind
dass das wahrscheinlich nicht gut ist
klappt kann ich unter umständen denken
aber ich habe kein problem die dann
wegzuwerfen wahrscheinlich weil es hat
mich bewogen
kostenschub kauft hat ganz einfach ein
schuh der stark verklebt ist der stadt
verliebt ist den man nicht
auseinandernehmen kann kann ihn
reparieren das heißt jeder schuster
lehnen das ab verlieren was super
günstig produziert sind wenn nicht von
freunden produkt kaufe und weiß was die
da für energie reingesteckt haben haben
beziehungen und kennen den ihre
geschichte die jahre ohne freunde wohnen
inzwischen hat wie lange wir da drei
entwickelt haben wie viel herzblut drin
steckt was da an innovationen auch wenn
man sie nicht immer gleich sieht quasi
drin steckt die tragen die schuhe schon
mit einem anderen stolze
man kriegt ein schuh für 130 euro also
mit dem bausatz
rohmaterialien drin sind die eigentlich
normalerweise in einem schuh verbaut in
der er 200 euro grenze liegt und das
heißt dass bauern lohnt sich ich bekomme
einen super werden schuhe und ich kann
ihn reparieren wir haben irgendwie am
anfang angefangen das denkmodell
aufzubauen haben gesagt wir wollen
unbedingt reine materialien verarbeiten
umweltfreundliche materialien
verarbeiten die auch der kunde barfuß am
fuß tragen kann das heißt dass halt
keine groben seil so in die haut
übertragen werden und haben das mit 99,4
prozent nachwachsenden rohstoffen
geschafft ms die sohle nimmt dessen
naturlatex was in frankreich per hand
gegossen
ist sogar flexibel hat halt ein ganz
anderer dämpfen als normale kunststoff
sole hat man noch eine einlage quasi die
da rein kommt und die schnürsenkel die
man natürlich dann hier und wenn man
ganz ganz ganz schnell war also eine
viertelstunde später sieht es quasi dann
so aus und das
ist er fertig punkt gibt es nicht mehr
viel zu sagen genau bei dem man alle
nähte reparieren kann genau
ich weiß nicht mehr leben aber sie
vielleicht dass er gezwungen sehen auch
gezogen sind langlebige und
nicht in shorts wir sind in einem lauf
drin das wird produziert an jeder ecke
immer mehr immer mehr immer mehr
und das rächt sich irgendwann mal ganz
böse für mich ist vom bild vom turm es
ist so als ob man immer höher und die
kraft das zusammen
das braucht man alles gar nicht so lieb
mir und so wichtig mir dinge sind
natürlich sind sind sind die menschen
meiner umgebung kannst du natürlich
wichtiger wir leben auf einer kugel die
kugel scheint endlos ist aber nicht
sondern wir treffen wir immer wieder auf
uns selber
was verleitet mich dazu immer weiter
gedankenlos zu konsumieren
obwohl ich es doch längst besser weiß
warum rackern wir uns ab und dinge zu
kaufen die wir nach kurzer zeit wieder
wegwerfen
vielleicht hat die psychologin irmgard
fuchs levy eine antwort für mich
ich glaube dass wir alle gerne jemand
besonderes sein möchten wir wollen was
besonderes sein wir wollen hervor
stechen aus der masse
und die
werbung vermittelt uns wenn du dieses
oder jenes produkt kauft dann bist du
was besonderes und im grunde werden wir
damit nur zu einem bestandteil der masse
wenn wir sehr ängstliche menschen sind
dann kann es sein dass uns eine sache
die wir kaufen ein gefühl der sicherheit
vermittelt oder wenn wir eher depressiv
sind wenn wir
repressiver charakter sind dann kann es
sein dass uns
eine sache die wir kaufen tröstet
und und beruhigt und oder wenn wir ein
eher narzisstischer charakter sind dann
kann er uns prestige
verleihen
das sind wir sehr verfügbar nicht wenn
man uns sagt mit diesem produkt dadurch
so unwiderstehlich wenn ein mensch
annähernd selbstwertgefühl besitzt also
wenn also mit sich zufrieden ist dann
wird er allem was er noch besitzt auch
wert verleihen er wird sich da nicht
einfach davon trennen und das
wegschmeißen
sondern er wird es einbeziehen in sein
leben es wird zu seinem leben
dazugehören
man kauft der die dinge man hat ja
arbeitskraft eingesetzt
man hat er dafür gearbeitet dass man was
kaufen kann und wenn man das dann zu
bereitwillig wegwirft wirft man doch
irgendwie auch ein stück der eigenen
person und der eigenen arbeit weg
wenn sie ein smartphone haben dann
drücken sie darauf oder wischen drauf
und dann tut sich was und dann können
sie so etwas haben was sie vorhin
erwähnt haben nämlich ein gefühl von
macht ich muss nicht viel machen und
dann erscheint die welt vor mir aber
wenn sie beim freund klingeln dann
müssen sie sich mit ihm
auseinandersetzen
dann kann es sein dass der in jacques du
heute geht es mir nicht so gut heute
bin ich nicht bereit dann müssen sie die
enttäuschung verarbeiten und so weiter
also ein anderer mensch ist eine große
aufgabe
[Musik]
wenn man uns dann ersatz anbietet in
form von
so genannten
sachwerten oder ding werden dann greifen
wir darauf zurück weil das oft einfacher
erscheint
und das problem in unserer zeit ist eben
dass diese ding werte oder diese
sachwerte und nicht nähren sie verändern
nichts an unserer situation
und daher haben die natürlich leichtes
spiel die uns dann immer wieder etwas
neues anbieten wollen und sagen na ja es
gibt noch was besseres ich habe noch
etwas was durch zufriedener macht was
dich beliebte macht
und deswegen geraten wir doch in so ein
kreislauf und zufriedenheit wieder
ersatzbefriedigung wieder
unzufriedenheit und es kommt dann zu
einer gier die eigentlich nicht spielbar
ist
ich lese noch einmal mary shelleys 200
jahre alten frankenstein roman
ihr geschöpf ist das erste menschliche
erzeugnis dass eine stimme bekommen hat
und was sagt es
es beklagt dass es von seinem schöpfer
nicht geliebt wird und
dafür will es sich rächen
die botschaft ist klar
unsere erzeugnisse wollen von uns
respektiert werden
wenn wir das nicht tun werden sie unheil
über uns bringen
war vielleicht
tun sie das ja bereits
[Musik]